everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
number six of our cover to the 2020
canada's tournament we'll go ahead and
jump into it why it's gonna be played by
yon the poem to G he's had a very good
tournament he sits atop of the the
tournament we looked at him play a game
in game number five and ended up winning
that his opponent not having the best
tournament that is DHing lien he started
out with two losses then surprisingly
came back in one game number three
against Fabiano Caruana and a game that
no one expected him to win having the
tournament he was having one of the
favorites to win this tournaments he has
had two draws since then comes in and
needs a much-needed victory against yaa
now luckily for England Yann came into
this game and pretty much told everyone
was not feeling well was gonna be going
for a quick draw after today they do
have a rest day so wanted to just get a
quick draw take his lead going into the
rest day but we'll see how that ends up
for him starts out with E 4 E 5 and then
f3 knight c6 Bishop b5 so getting into
the right Lopez yesterday when we looked
at this it was the Birdland offense but
we see a 6 bishop back here to a force a
little bit different line then we're
used to seeing Knight to f6 castle on
the kingside and then after a Bishop to
e6 we see d3 this is the modern line
something we don't see all that often
but decides to go ahead and play
something a little bit outside the
ordinary I would say this is more of a
draw line but that seems to be what he
is going for but she comes back here to
a b3 and then after pond d6 solidifying
the pawn chain plays a 3 this is
preparing for if the knight were to come
here to a5 they can always bring his
bishop back here to a2 first decides to
castle on the King side Knight to c3 and
then an interesting move from black and
that is Knight to a5 now Knight to a5 is
the threat that black is has on the
board but that's usually just setting up
for the pawn to come Bay 3 and then you
don't always see Knight to a5 because
Jim Bishop comes back here to 82 and
this is a move that Bobby Fischer like
to play a lot getting as bish
about here to see four and then bring it
back to a two and just putting constant
pressure on his opponent once the pond
comes up here to e5 and they solidify
with d6 this long light square diagonal
is a real threat that white has for the
rest of the game
so usually don't see Knight to a5 here
but decides you know let's go ahead and
try that out here Bishop comes back here
to a2 and then Bishop to e6 definitely
needs to stop this threat that we have
here pawn up to a B for attacking the
knight Bishop comes down and takes rook
recaptures here want to make sure you
don't take the knight it could be
tempting say yeah I'll do something cute
and take with your pond here bishop
comes back all of a sudden White has
double pawns here on the a file black
has a pretty good position has the
bishop pair definitely not what you want
to do so correctly decides to go ahead
and recapture with his rook here on
night 2 a2 that comes back to c6 work
here is done Bishop to g5 Queen to a d7
Bishop takes Bishop recaptures and then
Knight to d5 now attacking this bishop
now as far as where black can really go
to from here has a few options could
play Bishop comes back to d8 it's no
longer under threats you know can't
obviously come to e8 here are East 7
with the Queen wants to protect the
bishop here could come back to d8 but
then really all this Queen is doing is
just sitting there protecting the square
but why could just completely avoid that
line and go a completely different route
and start to push forward with maybe c4
and just say yeah don't have your queen
involved to add all into the game
another option that you could see is
Knight to e7 yes this this could just
force the move right here
that is going to be fine I think for
black stand points he would eventually
bring his King over here to h8 then
swing his rook to the semi open file on
g8 as well but just having your opponent
hang out here with a nice little outpost
on d5 is pretty frustrating the other
move that he has and that's exactly what
he play
is a five and say it don't really like
any of those moves I like my setup that
I have in the center I'm gonna start
pushing on the Queen side of the board
now we see rook swing over to a b2 wants
to protect it in a little bit different
way than some others mites after the
recaptures here it does have his pawn
here on b4 does not want to have his
rook hanging out here on a 2 after he
decides to recapture like he did now the
bishop comes back to d8 pawn up to a c4
so starting to break open the center of
the board here Knight to d4 Knight
recaptures and then the pawn captures
here all know I like White's position he
has a good central control the center
with his pawns he has a nice little
outpost with his knight here on a d5 yes
both sides are equal in material but
black does have these central pawns and
they are all doubled up not exactly how
black would like it very easy for white
to now get his queen involved to the
board have both of his rooks what black
really needs to do is take over the game
open up the center and then really
control it with his bishop definitely
going to be difficult but that's what
blacks gonna be looking to do here Queen
to c2 rook over here to e8 just
centralizing a little bit pawn to g3
pawn takes Queen recaptures here and
then pawn to c6 forcing the knight to
come back and I comes back here to f4
Bishop comes down says yeah I'm gonna go
ahead and take this Knights here White's
not looking to get double pawns on the F
file so instead decides to bring his
knight back here to e2 also its hacking
this pawn here on d4 now d5 looks a
little bit awkward because it says okay
yeah I'm attacking your Queen you can
just take my pawn here on d4 this is
obviously gonna be a trap that would be
a huge mistake for the Queen to take
here on a t4 because Bishop to f6 is
devastating attacking the Queen Queen
can capture as soon as the Queen moves
it can't even get to a safe Square to
defend this rook this rook is gonna fall
here on at b2 so does not do that
obviously
and then we see Yan play pawn takes on
d5 after the pawn captures then the
Queen comes back here to b3 will be able
some point put some pressure on the
central double pawns but at the time
being decided does not want to worry
about that and so it brings his queen
back here to a b3 starts to push on the
kingside the board it's very difficult
to see how being lean is going to
continue put a lot of pressure but
decides to start with a CH 5 and then B
5 over here so had the best pawn rule
number one if you have a passed pawn
start to push that as much as possible
and that's exactly what he does h4 b 6
here pawn comes down here to h3 just
stopping some of the squares that this
king can go to if there's ever an attack
on this back rank here king - h1 recover
here to b6 trying to stop this pass pawn
definitely have to make sure that you
don't allow your opponent to push any
further up the board here rook to b1
just trying to put all the material on
this B file this tends to be or this
looks to be the most important file on
the board right here Bishop comes back
here a to d8 and then Queen up here to
b5 you can tell why the knight didn't
come here to the 4 same reason as before
the bishop could just come here to f6
not necessarily the setup that white is
looking for so we continue Queen comes
down here to a g4 attacking the Knights
here on e 2 and then Queen takes on d5
now it's this looks to be a mistake it's
it's difficult to see exactly the best
move maybe Queen to f5 still holding
down this material here on a d5 not
actually sure why he decided to come
down here to g4 but yan went ahead and
played Queen takes here on d5 gets that
material back maybe black said yeah I'm
just not gonna be able to hold on to
this material as long as I'd want to
anyway so I'm gonna go ahead and bring
it here doesn't really have a strong
attack though can't take the knight here
on youtube because the rook is
protecting it Queen comes down here or
the rook comes down there excuse me to
a5 and this is a trap what this is
really a sacrifice you don't want to
take right here on a5 because then the
Queen can come too
uf3 check and there's no way to stop the
checkmate here on g2 so needs to make
sure that he holds the Queen on this
long light to our diagonal since that's
why we see the move Queen to c6 then
rook swings over here to c5 same thing
trying to get this Queen off this long
diagonal I think being leans look at
this and says I'm starting to lose the
position here so I need to just see if I
can get white to make a huge mistake
here he does not decide to play queen up
here to e8 check after the King moves
now Knight comes down here to g1 this is
now protecting the critical square here
on f3 that ding was looking to go to
rook comes down captures the pawn here
on b6 but that's fine because then the
bishop is gonna fall here on d8 after
the rook falls rook recaptures and then
rook comes down here to c1 so this is
pinning down the knight here can no
longer take if the Queen comes to f3 so
white does need to strike an attack here
that's exactly what he does and Queen to
h4 pretty much puts the nail in the
coffin this is check also forces his
opponent to exchange Queens no other way
around this after the Queen takes pawn
recaptures here and after rook to d1 we
see f3 and Bingley and decides to go
ahead and resign in this spot if you're
curious why he would respond because
after the rook takes here then the
knight could take at this pawn on h3 and
this is actually protecting the pawn
because if the rook takes then I can
swing up here check for King the rook
here on f3 so no real way for black to
continue if he tries to push his pawn
maybe rook to c3 his kinking start to
get involved into the game worked down
here c2 can attack the pawn here if he
tries to push it
maybe Knight e r g5 check in between
move but then rook to d3 you can see
there's no way to defend this pawn and
the king is not going to be able to make
its way over here and help as well so
white should be able to just overwhelm
his opponent on the King 7 bore so
Dingley knowing
that yawn is such a good in-game player
decides to go ahead and resign and take
it into the rest day they are not having
the best game only has two points out of
the potential six in the first six
rounds young on the other hand is
looking pretty good in first place
four-and-a-half points out of the
possible six and he goes into the rest
day hopefully he can feel better after
the rest day while this was an exciting
game an even bigger news in the Candace
tournament that is an HD re after 20
games in the Candace tournament remember
he played an entire Candace tournament
in the past 1-0 drew every single one
came into this tournament drew the first
five games cuz why not that's what he
does he comes into the sixth game and he
wins his first candidates game ever now
only took him seven hours and 98 moves
in his game but he ended up getting a
victory so congratulations to the draw
master himself in HD also
congratulations to young going into the
second break here with the lead
hopefully you guys are enjoying this -
enjoying this tournament we do have
eight more round so a lot of chest left
to go it's anyone's tournament yawn
definitely looks to be the leader in the
clubhouse but in second place is in the
AL in those two players actually go up
head-to-head in round number seven so
definitely will be looking forward to
that but again thanks for watching I'll
see you guys in round number seven in
two days